[Music]
at their very best technologies of media
are engines of empathy right cinema
perhaps the pinnacle the Cathedral a
communication technology allows you to
experience the world from another's
point of view ultimately at its best
acting as a catalyst for you to be more
compassionate and empathic towards the
other now looking towards the future
there's a lot of talk now about virtual
reality the oculus rift has finally
captured the imagination of the public
and this is now becoming real
the idea of fully immersive
technologically mediated dream worlds
you know rendered mind spaces where you
literally inhabit another world portals
to another world these are not virtual
realities these are going to be in real
virtuality and what is this ultimately
all about well Terence Mckenna says
these technologies will allow us to
share our dreams with one another
everybody will have essentially a cosmos
of the imagination where they can build
cathedrals of the mind
imagine the intimacy that becomes
possible when people meet and they say
hey do you want to come visit my world
do you want to see what it's like to be
inside my head
what kind of intimacy it's like turning
ourselves inside out the metaphor used
by Terence Mckenna is that of the octopi
this is what becomes possible the octopi
transfigure eights
to merge with its environment it
literally wears its linguistic intent
outside its skin it wears its mind its
nervous system outside its skin its way
of communicating is something that can
be beheld language becomes something
that can be visually beheld us humans
grunts and voices and funny faces to try
to envy you to read what one another is
thinking and feeling imagine if with
virtual reality we all become like
octopi and where our minds outside our
skin imagine the intimacy that becomes
possible this is really what it sights
me about virtual reality about these
sacred modalities of intimacy exchange
and shared intersubjectivity that become
possible think about that
[Music]